[Music]
there were a lot of endings there was a
lot that went on in episode yeah in
terms of I guess Bryce's ending it
pisses me off but again I I kind of knew
it was coming because it's realistic so
I think they made the right call with
that aren't you are transferring yeah
yeah I'm gonna start over
lucky you
Justin Prentiss reacting to the season
finale of 13 reasons why season to his
character Brice Walker gets only three
months probation after sexually
assaulting multiple women is that the
point that justice was not really served
yeah you know it's interesting because I
think there were different forms of
justice throughout the show in terms of
actual legal justice Bryce just kind of
gets a slap on the wrist and a you know
don't do it again you little rascal
which is so screwed Bryce's is
privileged comes from a powerful family
he's a straight white male and so it's
easier for him to get off and we see
that happening all the time and it sucks
I know fans are gonna be super pissed
off but you should be pissed off because
that's you know that's the reality right
now the show ends with an almost school
shooting and clay of course prevents it
from happening but it seems so
reflective of what continuously is
happening how do you speak to that and
what do you think that says about your
show we try and stay as current as
possible we have a bunch of different
storylines this season all kind of
touching on all of these important
issues mass shootings guns are obviously
a big one again just disclaimer our
characters are kids in high school and
and it they are dramatized events and it
is a fictional show and if you're in the
position of clay go to an adult call my
won-won there there are better ways to
handle that situation but you know our
our characters are flawed and I think
that's kind of a beautiful thing - clay
doesn't always make the right decisions
and I think that's more human than
anything because just you don't want to
do this I'm glad nothing happened but
who knows if we did the third season I
guess this is why we need a season 3
there so there's a lot of questions left
unanswered where do you think the story
goes from there I I would love to do a
third season they haven't told us
Netflix I said anything
I hope they tell us soon because they
were all we're all very anxious to find
out I still think there is more to
explore with with the with the fallout
you know it doesn't end there
just because clay stopped this incident
from happening doesn't mean that Tyler's
okay in body and mind
so yeah I think there's there's more
Road
to explore and and we as a cast for for
sure I'm excited to explore it further
if they let us and what about Chloe's
pregnancy Oh things that she changed her
mind about testifying because she knew
that she was I think it's certainly a
possibility I think I think that along
with looking at Bryson in the eye and
him being there made it way harder than
she thought it was going to be to single
him out Bryce's is very manipulative and
as we saw in the flashback when they
were kids
he wasn't always this monster of a
person so there are bits of goodness and
Bryce a weird way Bryce seems like he
could protect and provide right right
like a wealthy family the kid's gonna
have a college fund you know but at the
same time you know all of this stuff is
coming to light and and Bryce's Empire's
starting to crumble and so I'm sure her
character is very very conflicted I
think that the topic of abortion would
be something that is explored then I
think it very much it could be I think
it very much could be and it would be
interesting to see how they handle it
because from my point of view Bryce
comes from a powerful family and they
have a way of making things disappear so
I don't know it could be very
interesting yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]